[Música]
hola bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en esta
oportunidad vamos a conversar con pablo
gonzález él es periodista se encuentra
en este momento en la ciudad de stepánek
en la capital de la región de nagorno
karabaj a una región en disputa entre
las fuerzas independentistas el ejército
de armenia y el ejército de azerbaiyán
pablo hemos visto en los últimos días
intensos bombardeos allí en la capital
de nagorno karabaj la ciudad de estepa
naker cómo está la situación allí como
es el día a día en esta ciudad así donde
usted se encuentra
a la situación pues la verdad es
bastante inusual para un núcleo urbano
como muy bien como comentas todos los
días
y es en la ciudad todos los días empieza
a diferentes horas suena la alarma de
que nos avisan de los ataques nos avisa
dos ataques aéreos porque a veces hay
ataques por artillería puedes pesados a
veces hay ataques con drones entonces
las calles están vacías las tiendas
están cerradas hay tensión la mayoría de
la gente civil no los todo mujeres y
niños han evacuado la gente que queda
está en refugios antibombas de ohl y
bueno es una es una situación totalmente
anómala para lo que vendría a ser una
ciudad pablo ya usted nos menciona algo
de la población de los civiles que están
en este fuego cruzado en la mayoría de
la población ha permanecido allí ha
evacuado a la vecina armenia se
mantienen entonces en los refugios hay
algún tipo de emergencia humanitaria o
algún tipo de situación difícil por la
que están pasando en términos
humanitarios más allá de la situación
que ya es complicada
bueno según los datos que ha
proporcionado las autoridades de esta
república autoproclamada del área
cerca de más de la mitad de la población
unos 75 mil de unos 145 146 mil personas
han abandonado han abandonado o se han
desplazado a zonas más seguras es decir
que tenemos más de la mitad de la
población que bien o bien es refugiada
en armenia o bien es hay de pino o una
persona desplazada dentro del propio
estado
realmente hay bastante solidaridad y yo
creo que todavía no llega a una
catástrofe humanitaria como podría ser
dos sitios tienen comida tienen
alojamientos tienen medicinas pero sí
que es una situación bastante difícil
sobre todo si se prolonga en el tiempo
que eso es lo que son lo que más
preocupa no que esta situación se
prolongue el tiempo que se destruyeron
muchas infraestructuras que no tengan
casas a donde volver y que esas casas
pues no tengan electricidad es decir luz
que no tengan gas que no tengan agua no
unos mínimos vitales hoy en día además
teniendo en cuenta que el invierno ya
está a la vuelta de las quienes las
condiciones climáticas tampoco van a
ayudar entonces a los habitantes en
estas difíciles condiciones que se les
están
en tanto pablo háblenos de su trabajo
como periodista hay gran cantidad de
prensa internacional allí cubriendo este
este conflicto hay seguridad que puede
ser usted de su labor allí
bueno hay cantidad hay una cantidad
razonable de prensa internacional aunque
yo diría que hay una gran cantidad de
pensante racional ha habido por lo menos
hasta la fecha dos periodistas heridos
de gravedad ha habido varios periodistas
heridos leves es difícil trabajar porque
si están bombardeando las ciudades y
este pancarta está muy en la retaguardia
y aún así está bajo fuego he visitado
núcleos urbanos que están mucho más
cerca de la línea de frente como podría
ser martelly
marta care o jardín y ahí es incluso
mucho más peligroso entonces la labor
periodística es difícil hay quienes la
está haciendo pero sí que no yo os
agradezco mucho que podamos hablar
porque realmente sí que parece que hay
una falta de interés
generalizada por un conflicto que es muy
serio la verdad es que están muriendo
mucha gente y es una es una guerra total
no en la que se utilizan la artillería
drones tanques
infantería avanzada pd entonces es
sorprende un poco la falta de interés
aunque los tradicionales que estamos en
el terreno pues lo estamos haciendo lo
mejor que podemos pablo pues le
agradecemos estos minutos que nos ha
concedido aquí en france 24 para darnos
a conocer de primera mano la situación
allí en este pan a quererte la capital
de nagorno karabakh a ustedes muchas
gracias por su sintonía y pueden seguir
con la programación de france 24
[Música]